push it push it push it with your
[ __ ] real building yeah
come up your book I must as long as you
don't like walk on my she's like you
jump upon that one on that one I will
show you wait check this out you can
jump up here Oh what she was like oh
just please don't step on that then you
can walk behind it good girl
[Laughter]
hi guys as soon as she heard us both in
here she's going on today
um the first thing I wanted to say and
some very very sad news I just found out
that Stuart Gordon has passed away
reanimate er Dagon yeah from beyond yeah
yeah Oh was he 72 I think how problems
for a while because I did see that the
last thing that he had really worked on
because I've you know he kind of went
out of movies later on and he went into
like more into stage work the last thing
he worked on him I didn't know this and
now I kind of want to see it he did like
a musical or a stage play or something
about that about that German guy that
like wanted to eat that other guy and
like you've got somebody to voluntarily
come and like cook and eat him yeah like
Stuart Gordon
and I'm like damn fart in a spacesuit no
I don't eat vitamin you don't know okay
like like I said cuz he's always kind of
doing that sort of like experimental
kind of [ __ ] I mean well and there's
kind of been a trend like the last
probably 10 15 years of music or
musicals that's based on sweet I'm like
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that you wouldn't
normally yeah it's not like
unprecedented so yeah so yeah he passed
away and we've gosh we've reviewed we
reviewed Dagon we reviewed from we did
from beyond didn't we
I'm pretty sure we didn't I don't know
and we did reanimate her yeah we also do
prior to pre animator although I think
that was Brian yes oh hey stop it again
she's like what yeah mostly yeah yeah
Thank You castle for you we also
reviewed castle ring so we've actually
done more stories than I thought that
gives me a chance to plug color from
space yeah we got to see it again
I bought it on blu-ray yeah we're gonna
watch me you guys yet again that [ __ ]
was good if you guys haven't seen it
good streaming is extreme edition is
probably streaming now and it's not on
their streamer brand-new movies now well
yeah you knew that was gonna happen it
was kind of like I just saw their the
AMC just started streaming bloodshot
yeah their app I mean you got to pay a
lot like I said are you gonna pay like
20 bucks to actually buying it you're
buying is it still cheaper than two
movies yeah it's it's also for sale on
Amazon
yeah yeah come on buy it I'm gonna buy a
hard copy I'm not gonna buy a digital
copy
I would rather for 20 bucks thing kiss
my ass I want a physical product yeah
for that kind of money
yeah yeah right some some stuff you just
might have to
wait longer right what I mean but yeah I
just noticed that today because I was
curious to see like if they put like new
[ __ ] up
well the thing about the AMC app it's
like all the new [ __ ] is up and they put
a bunch of old movies up to they were
like cheap they're like just like if
you'd read them on YouTube or whatever
yeah there's a lot of stuff that's not
gonna survive the apocalypse so that it
like I said it's going just along what I
said the comic book industry and comic
book shops that's that's coming to
diamond comics closed and that's what
kept that afloat or some people say no
that the diamond comics actually was
destroying it with their [ __ ] up
policies but that's a thing of the past
now yeah I just noticed like some other
cuz okay like I said you know a lot of
fast food places and stuff we're doing
good yeah but I just read an article
that Burger King at least in the UK they
decided to close but what they're gonna
do is they're not gonna pay rent on
their buildings like they negotiated
with like their landlords and stuff to
not pay the rent so thing so they can
still pay their employees right so
they're gonna pay people as though which
is pretty rad actually so get [ __ ] on
your Burger King there's a couple people
that show up in the comments if I can
listen to the doctors and it look we are
listening to the doctors it's just that
you know some people want to interpret
this in a different way they want to
make it worse than what it is they're
just gonna slow down the spread of it
they're not gonna stop spread that well
you can't stop you can't stop it right
it's better to slow it down
yeah because otherwise otherwise we'll
be [ __ ] later on you'll suffer more
casualties if you don't slow it down
yeah but the thing is those you don't
have to slow it down you don't have to
lock everywhere down you just lock
they're gonna find out where they are
where the affected cases are you're
gonna keep that place locked down
they're gonna free up everybody else
they're gonna put everybody else back
yeah like I said well depending on kind
of where you are I mean in the right
population areas right but yeah so that
the [ __ ] civilization fall apart
yeah hail to pay if they did although
like I said if they let everybody run
around with the disease though then
civilization will fall apart just a
couple months from now everybody gets
actually I saw an analysis of what would
happen if they just did absolutely
nothing and there's still
be that bad well just more people would
die well it wouldn't be a civilization
civilization ending event if you just
let it ride it's not deadly enough yeah
it's not deadly enough I mean you know
if you're talking about thirty percent
mortality some long along a level of
like the Black Death then yeah it might
end a civilization but now with the
mortality rate that you have now you
could actually just let that [ __ ] run a
while you people would die about five
percent probably three to five percent
but it would all be within that older
age bracket most of them I was gonna say
that one of the things because you said
you wanted to bring this up one of the
things that uh I guess be like eBay
sellers it's um yeah that are getting
desperate
yeah to sell their stuff as you would
because a lot of them are like smaller
cuz I could buy a lot [ __ ] right so I
have some bread there gargoyle 85 which
are kind of like 1985 versions the cargo
their improved a little bit but just by
looking at them they look like those
same glasses from Terminator 1 yes
they're in homage of that Terminator
what I do like the Halloween yeah I got
the jacket
engineer boots and I needed those
glasses and now you have them yeah I
could even what you know what because I
I could probably they make a shirt too
like a reproduction of that shirt and
you had it probably get something like
that but no I could do [ __ ] terminator
it's so much easier to do Halloween
nowadays because it's like so many
people do cosplay like not just for
Halloween but to go into conventions and
stuff so it's like there's [ __ ] Etsy
sellers that make [ __ ] that looks
exactly like the movie like if I want to
pay money you know yeah but now I
already have to cut my hair like most
guys would I just had to let my hair
grow out our friend Matt did it was
actually pretty good
yeah meeting terminator there was a lot
of stuff he didn't have though yeah for
the first guy
but I think he's done it several years
and around yes because he didn't have
his glasses he had similar yes right
well I like I said I don't blame them at
their [ __ ] usually $80 yeah but now
somebody on eBay Adam yeah some you know
and I first saw Matt 45 minutes oh man
that's a good deal and then I checked
that wait a minute they're in Miami a
seller in Miami had them for $33
delivered i morally opposed to paying
more than $12 for a pair of okay well I
mean for myself I would never in our
goals you could yeah yeah I can justify
Gaga's a little bit because their
ballistic rated safety glasses for
shootings in combat they may come in
different colors and different styles
that's not what more fair enough it's a
combat glass yeah you could wear that in
the service you know I mean they make
different colors you service you
probably wear the yellow ones are the or
the clear ones or a slightly smoked once
you know yeah alright then I'll give $40
for that but any more than that I think
it's a shooting glass I mean honestly I
think like you know it's it's a
different price point for each thing but
I'm always kind of like up to a certain
point um you know up to a certain price
yes the price matters but after a
certain price point and like I said it's
different for every product after a
certain price point you were not getting
a you're only paying for it man you know
the packaging like you know though it's
not gonna get any better than one that
was like X cost you know the snow
glasses that bob was wearing in
spectre-1 hit funny looking glasses yeah
those things are like [ __ ] 1,200
bucks so I've heard
yeah they're like cuz I thought I said
haven't you smoked glass ah nope nope
every now and that's what you wear with
your [ __ ] $3,200 Rolex or petit
Phillipe or some [ __ ] like that you know
it's just not real it's like not for
real peeps now for real people
it's for imaginary people like you go to
that mall liking that expensive a small
that's right exactly
if you go on dan bells channel because
like I said we love he doesn't just do
dead malls he does like all he doesn't
creepy abandoned places he does like
shitty hotel rooms but he went to this
one mall it's in Miami what's called Bal
Harbour or something like that and
Americans don't go there it's just
foreigners well I just well it's just
like all rich be just like this huge
open like every single store is like a
designer store um you know they have
like the cars you know how in the malls
they pull the cars and they're like the
new models or whatever this car is like
Lamborghinis Ferraris how much was the
how much did this [ __ ] car cost like
a quarter of a million dollars or some
[ __ ] that was more than that I was just
like looking at the monthly payment and
I'm like holy crap that's like three
months when he handed him a $45,000
watch remember that and like it was
nothing just handed him a 40 that
[ __ ] beautiful watch and and it's
like it's for rich people you can tell
because you could smoke in there
yes mobile we're going man they don't
[ __ ] put up money that no smoking
[ __ ] they got too much money well as
the poor people you know we cracked me
up it's like I know this is kind of like
a weird like side track and everything
but I was because I said on the show
yesterday that I've been watching that
series that French series Marianne and I
finished watching that so I'm definitely
gonna review that for the matinee show
so much smoking on that show you guys I
didn't realize that it's like cuz you
know in the u.s. like most people have
to quit you know what I mean like I quit
II quit you know so yeah some people
have gone to making but it's now you
don't really even see a lot of vaping
anymore because I feel like people are
kind of getting sick of that too but
it's like in in the in Marianne the
front soon that since new it just came
out like last year man everybody's just
smoking like chimneys like all the time
and I'm like holy crap but do they still
do that in France it they were just just
doing that for the show I don't really
know yeah I tell you one thing though is
that if you guys are smoking you want to
quit smoking feet I would have never
quit smoking without vaping and he quit
like immediately like as soon as you
quit as soon as you started beeping yeah
you quit smoking
some people can't seem to do that but I
did they well the thing I guess it
depends on what is your taping yeah some
people it takes them a little while to
get the hang of it because it's not it's
not quite the same it can tell straight
in they want to do it in there they want
a mouth hit like they do up a cigarette
right can't do it yeah it's like a
different experience it's good to have
because I mean for awhile like I'd have
the vape in my office and it'd be good
because if I wanted a cigarette I could
just like pick it up and I felt like I
was doing something that was sort of
approximating smoking but it wasn't
quite as bad um but you know some people
I don't know they they make like herbal
cigarettes too which I think are not is
that don't have any nicotine and don't
have any tobacco in them yeah
hopefully not eating which is what I was
made for maybe two years something like
that after a couple years I'm super into
it like you were even mixing your own so
yeah after a couple years I'm like
really wasn't getting out of it cuz I
got I'd been at zero nicotine for about
a year
yeah I just forget to take it yeah cuz
you get cuz you get like the vape you
can get it with nicotine in the door
without or but different percentages
yeah you can just what we did was we
just started out zero yeah and then you
couldn't tell the difference it didn't
matter by that time and then yeah gets
to the point to where you're like going
places and then you forget to take your
[ __ ] mod with you and then you go
like that's yeah I don't really matter
that I didn't take that's what happened
to me yeah and then eventually you go
like [ __ ] the mod yeah you don't need it
I had it because like I said I had it
sitting on my desk in my office and then
like I would realize that I'd gone like
a whole day or two yeah got it man I got
a Bungie liquid I got I can say it right
now although I forget about it yeah but
yeah I'm talking about other series that
will probably be reviewing for the
matinee show we are only one episode
into this but it already it looks like
the craziest [ __ ] oh yeah Tiger King
they just added it on [ __ ] Netflix
right and it's like I was like okay well
we got to review that because I heard
somebody talking about it
this is crazy [ __ ] you'll ever see it's
like a true story like a true crime same
thing and like I said we I had finished
watching Mary Ann because I still have
like four or five episodes left of that
so we only saw the first episode of
tiger King but I'm like already this
looks like [ __ ] insane we don't say I
don't want to say we have to watch the
rest yeah like today it's it's about
this guy he's here in Florida and
they've got a lot of people well he
started in Florida already moved
somewhere else you have a lot of people
like that here in Florida these big
farms and bars a lot of mountain views
and there's one of them where there was
one of my nila they had a bunch of lions
and tigers he the dude that owned it he
used to be one of the Tarzan's I think
he's an old guy yeah yeah he just loves
lions and tigers and God he didn't get
any trouble but this dude did he mean
he's got almost 200 big cats and there's
a bunch of people after but you look at
the guy I don't want to say white trash
or anything nobody's trash it's very
sweet of you there's always a group of
people where you then I mean kind of
like the jeans have kind of [ __ ] they
have a lot of unpopular jeans older
generations you know you can see who
comes from that I mean it's like we
haven't like I know roughly the Outland
the case we haven't got that far the
series yet he's trying to be he's a nice
guy if he asked me he's trying to be
nice he does care about those cats but I
think it's an addiction I don't think he
knows what exactly what's plus I think
he's not entirely right you know I don't
think he's a little bit crazy but then
there's I did some of the [ __ ] that
happened so far I mean like he's got 200
cats and people are trying to take these
cats from him all right you have to kind
of balance [ __ ] out what would happen to
what they were taking from him oh those
cats are probably killed yeah it's like
what is the thing it's like there aren't
very many of them in the wild I don't
mind people having
animals like that if they're in there
anyway yeah if they're in a habitat if
they're you know monitored so they're
like taking care of them you know what I
mean if you know if there aren't a lot
of them in the wilds generally if there
are a lot of them in the wild then I
think they should stay in the wild
because that's where they should be
right that's that's what I mean I do
feel like so like I don't have any
problem with like some place like Animal
Kingdom or something like that where you
know they have like animals that you
know there aren't a lot of them in the
wild so they have like a breeding
program that's being undertaken with
like you know veterinarians and stuff
like that and they have all the
medicines and everything that's fine um
I don't think that you should just let
any Tom Dick and Harry a bunch of it
just in cages in his backyard it's like
not only it hurt yeah it's like not only
that you know but it's like that yeah
they could escape yeah um you know so
you have to like and probably if you're
just keeping them in a cage in your
backyard then obviously that means that
you're not really caring for them to the
best of you know which is probably the
best for that cat and like I said it's
probably not real good for your
neighbors either if they [ __ ] escape
and at the end of the first episode
spoiler alert
somebody gets their [ __ ] arm bitten
off yeah so you know I get kind of torn
between it because they're like they're
trying to take the cats from him but
chances are they kill a lot of the cats
if they did take the cash yeah and
nobody wants that an inner he's not
abusing the cats he likes the cats it's
just that he's got a lot of them they
don't they're not living like a big cat
they're living more like dogs you go in
there and pet them and they're happy and
they're there they're not skinny or they
they might they're not starving they're
eating I'd rather have them like that
than be put down you know I mean yes
that's probably what they would do yeah
I don't trust the [ __ ] state like
well we don't have a habitat for these
cats and we have to keep them to spec
and we can't really afford that
let's kill three-quarters of them the
other ones we might be able to
give these two can take care should even
like around here there's a wild
yeah or kill not build a bunch of bears
because one of them like attacked
somebody's yeah and that didn't happen
that's just a story that they told
killed seven innocent bears that they're
not pets but they just walk around
neighborhoods and ask for garbage if I
see him walking around all the time
they're not a threat I mean as long as
you don't like [ __ ] with them and jump
up in their face and that woman was not
attacked she was a woman from another
country that was afraid of the damn
bears she left a garage open and he will
go right into your garage we've seen him
do it yeah I've stopped bear from doing
it she saw me do it yeah he was going in
to get he was going in to see what was
in the fridge he's gonna open up
frigerator right you can open a fridge
yeah I would fold up says come on out of
there it's just they're not very big
most of them they're the size of a dog
of a big dog you know that one was how
tall to shoulder maybe three feet three
and four maybe four feet the shelter and
bear did not outweigh me I don't think
remember he was fairly large I've seen
bigger ones like the one that when we
came home from the club one night and
sitting in our driveway that one was
actually few approached black bear they
they they submit like have a dog you
know the dog puts a tail between his
legs and gets a scared look that's what
they do and you know anyway I just was
like hey bear no you can't go in there
neither [ __ ] anyway what happened
was is that she had a garage door open
and at the back of the garage she had a
garbage can and it walked in there go
get the garbage can
she came out of the garage door and
where she just stepped out with in
between in between and the garbage cans
or the bear world threatened like he was
cornered and next to that thing was was
a car in the garage they bear had no way
of getting out except through that woman
and it ran towards her it grabbed her
maghreb her drugged her a little bit to
move her out of the way and then let it
go and then and then
and then ran off it was not an attack
yes just trying to get out of there like
I said they you know when a you can't
corner an animal they they will freak
out yeah it was scared yeah I mean I'm
sure she was the woman we they're too
obvious and she was not injured that was
another thing she wasn't injured and so
what they do
Animal Control comes down here and kills
eight bears just local random [ __ ]
bears yeah I mean I'm a hotter I kill
[ __ ] but I eat it they just threw those
[ __ ] dead bot into those dead bodies
away yeah and it's really like killed
for nothing I mean one we built a
neighborhood in there yeah yeah and
they're not a big threat yeah they're
know through I haven't seen one for a
while now that I'm thinking about there
was one of them that kind of worried me
that what he was [ __ ] big really big
and he had an injured leg and he was
across the street one time yeah and a
bear like that can't they don't catch
anyway they're not up apex predator
they're more like a scavenger yeah they
look for [ __ ] to eat they don't chase
you they usually don't chase anything
down to eat it but they'll get frogs and
[ __ ] fish and turn over garbage cans
and you know they don't want any trouble
they they actually don't even like to
fight for food they they have a ready
supply they're not everywhere right but
that particular bear with the hurt leg
because he got hit by a car yeah they
ended up killing him he wasn't one of
the ones that they killed during that
eight yeah
eight eight bear slaughter was it he was
one of them because they thought that
and I kind of agreed with the assessment
that as he aged out he may have a
problem getting food and maybe he might
grab a person yeah he's got something
most likely he'd grab a child yeah be
like something like that small enough
that won't be able to get away from me
yeah grab it that's yeah that would be
the biggest threat he didn't do that I'm
just saying that that might not happen
right that's something that I can kind
of agree with that one but the other
ones they were telling young bears with
mama bear with their [ __ ] cubs and
[ __ ] that's I mean it was just because
it's in this area but
they had been here for a long time they
weren't bothering anybody thought they
were a threat you could just trap him
and relocate him and you know the answer
was as well we got so many of them okay
yeah it seemed that always kind of like
bother you know people are like well
he's sick cuz you even sometimes like
you know if I'm like bummed out cuz like
one time Gerber one time we were coming
home we were coming back from a walk and
we found like a little squirrel yeah and
it had fallen out of a tree and we like
and like busted his head yeah he never
regained conscious and yeah he was still
alive so we brought him home Oh Pookie
was freaking out I had I had a video but
she was like trying to get the hey she
wants to kill this world yeah and this
world already had a really bad day yeah
so uh but she was man she was freaking
out
yeah she could smell it and we tried to
like revive him that's like thought
maybe he would be okay but the next day
you know and it's like people say you
know oh there's lots of squirrels which
there are they're squirrels everywhere
but I was like well that doesn't mean
you should just like leave them talk to
our vent friend and he's like they
usually don't make it that's what we
yeah we figured he probably wouldn't but
like well we didn't want to just leave
him in the middle of the big he was
gonna die and just want to leave him in
the middle of the path like to get hit
by a bike or something like that he was
being eaten there live by ants when I
got to it it's like at least he could be
like we could put him like in the towel
and he'd be kind of warm and maybe
comfortable yeah but back to the guy
yeah you know wouldn't [ __ ] I asked
[ __ ] the cops about it when they were
talking about yeah they were parked in
for an hour when I came are they just
relocated because I got so many okay out
you know in in the more rural areas
there's a [ __ ] ton yeah there's lots of
them so they just having so many of them
I mean [ __ ] I've I'd be coming home like
from work and then in the afternoon like
five six o'clock and I saw like two or
three of them just like cruising across
people's yards do do
yeah you would think the day time to
think that a big animal like that a bear
you know would be valuable like
something that would be kind of rare but
evidently no they're [ __ ] everywhere
do you remember that one time that we
that I looked out our back our sliding
glass or in our bedroom and there was a
wounded deer yeah what is it a fly right
by our porch like right there yeah I
should have shot that deer yeah well
because I at first I didn't realize that
it was wounded that she was wounded she
was just like sitting there and I was
like look there's a deer right there and
then she got up and that leg got caught
in some kind of chain link fence or
something and that it was around for a
couple days but I never I'm in it I'm in
I'm not in an area where you were you
fired you know approach to the man that
shot that thing anyway cuz I called
animal control and he said oh yeah we
know about that one it'll die that was
that was the I says yeah that's kind of
slow death he goes that's nature and I
was like great and I was like can I kill
it they go now you know you're within
the city limits you can't shoot there
you can't if I should have done it
anyway yeah just you know I had
something that could have been pretty
quiet nobody wouldn't know that because
I felt so bad yeah that thinks I can
probably died over here a few weeks I
saw it over a period of a few weeks you
can still walk Seraph yeah but not
really not really and usually they come
to a bad end where they're that wounded
that's I mean it was like it was really
heartbreaking something else that'd be
bad to just walk around with a damn
dangling we always the show is it's all
swollen show us so cheerful was all slow
and then you know I mean around here
maggots and [ __ ] yeah all right so you
want to wrap this hair today all right
so it's Wednesday we'll probably talk to
you guys again tomorrow I'm putting up
some more horror stories tomorrow we're
gonna watch the rest of that tiger
things later so like I said we'll talk
about that on the matinee show and I'll
find something else new to watch do so
something else to look forward to
so we'll talk to you guys tomorrow